hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker I
took a break I ate some pizza I hugged
my dog I felt love for the first time in
a long time and I'm ready to lose all of
that so that I can play this stupid
stupid level again I feel the rage that
the game Bros felt towards Ross and I
just know that he'd be cackling like a
like a maniac later but it's not his
fault it's not that hard I think I was
just very very tense from companions
spring one and I let that spill over
into my gameplay four companions spring
- so I just need to not do that I need
to be a better bunkie bustard boo and
not let small things get to me because
it's the small things I may have said
that before I'm starting this off a
little too manic in my mind but it's
it's the small things it'll get ya it's
the small things that'll kill ya yeah
because if you don't if you don't if you
don't rush what I discovered is if you
don't rush and you have fun with it and
you try to enjoy yourself and not not
forget that this has a point zero four
percent completion rate which is awesome
just totally amazing but so long as I
remember that this is very difficult so
I need to take my time and if I'm not
gonna if I have any hope of ever ever
ever ever what did I do
oh man it can have been that long I
can't be that not used to the controls
anymore I'm doing good I'm doing good I
just have to be careful and calm and
shut the hell up every once in a while
that's my problem as I've said there
many times before when you're dedicating
a lot of your brain cells to talking and
making up a lot of bull like the
[ __ ] factories in my brain are just
working overtime you don't have a lot of
time to think about exactly what you're
doing so here we go
I really don't even know if the twirl is
necessary there but it's definitely
necessary there okay well got it okay
now we're good now we're good now we're
good and then this guy's breeze whoa hey
how's it going oh god oh god yes
that's so weird that's scary oh god
that's not what I wanted
Oh God son of a [ __ ] oh whoa I didn't
mean to do that I'm sorry sir okay come
on what is that baloney
what kind of malarkey is this like this
level it just gets you in places where
you have no chance of coming back from
but it's so rare that I would get in
that place in the first place so how do
I do it all the time anyway
oh god oh god oh god
it's a weird tingly pleasant feeling
when it doesn't screw you oh okay that
was my own fault I need to stop having
so much coulis and if you don't know
what hubris is read up on some shakes /
come on thank you I don't know what I
think program I think I think Ross went
to Nintendo headquarters and programmed
an annoying delay on that one just to be
completely random at all time so that
you never know exactly when it's gonna
come out who's out before it's you're
predictable and what's squeaked I have
no idea okay here we go
damnit damn Oh God not this again okay
it's okay it's okay
damn it Oh No oh no everything's wrong
ah just float over the thing and we're
gonna be totally kosher ah damn it okay
we're fine
stop stop just stop stop it stop stop it
stop just stop
oh god damn it finally okay here we go
we're good we're good we're good rayray
we're good yes yes yes that worked out
beautifully I don't even need you oh not
you okay
fire again buddy Oh God not what I
wanted not what I wanted not what I
wanted not what I wanted oh that's so
stupid
that's so stupid it's so stupid I can do
that it's easy it's stupid but it's easy
yeah yeah I would love to see someone
try to do a speed run of this [ __ ]
all right okay all right back in the
saddle back in the sack I know I can do
this and I was actually when I was
off-camera I was coming up with all
these really important things that I
wanted to talk about while I was doing
this particular episode well that seems
to have all gone out of my brain because
I can't think of a single damn thing
that could help me I think I even
thought about bringing chica in here
just in case yes just in case has an
ability for a little bit of a stress
reliever because maybe she could keep me
sane but I think she'd be a little
worried at my constant screaming no you
don't okay
yeah come on happen I know why I know
why it's cuz I'm jumping like an idiot
it's cuz I'm jumping like an idiot I
need to just run on the conveyor because
I will go forward if I jump I'm gonna
lose my momentum I'm gonna lose
everything and I'm gonna die that's
what's gonna happen I know that's what's
gonna happen I need to not jump but it's
just thank you
it's just instinctual to jump I it's
like I feel like I'm gonna die if I
don't it's like panic I can't help it ah
boink oh I thought you could do this way
oh I'm not on those apparently oh well I
thought you could do that but that's
what I get for thinking doesn't work
anymore then I guess I'm not gonna be
able to do that
it's not about biscuit but it's okay
it's alright I am calm and collected
thank you God why it's totally like like
I thought it was like a certain point on
the ground that you need to be it's just
[ __ ] randomness isn't it gross rush
you bustard okay you'll notice there are
certain points in this level that I'm
playing that I have to get quiet on I
just got to make sure that I don't look
stupid and freak up on that one moment
come on oh god damn it
come on just go up the thing why is it
so hard
nailing it oh [ __ ] not nailing it what
the Frick are you doing thank you okay I
got it but I lost my shroom it was
probably the only shroom it's gonna get
me for a long time greats
okay maybe being small is gonna help me
running yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes and I know this is here cuz I
watched the grumps kid don't matter I
got it
hi here we go okay never mind then thank
you
damn it okay boring oh this is going to
be I know why here and got frustrated
this part oh come on hey no hey no hey
god dammit god dammit oh this is hard
it may look easy but I thought this
looked easy what I was watching them do
this it's naughty oh that's not easy
okay I just got to grab it and then drop
it at a very certain point okay no no no
he dt t he t TT he TT d there we go okay
now that I got that it's another bozer
but this one has a freakin oh hi hi hi
don't do that no no no not what I wanted
not what I wanted oh god oh god no oh
god why that's so stupid
I don't handle frustration we'll make
this way don't wait it's okay it's okay
I got this everything else up into that
point is easy it's easy street easy
peasy lemon squeeze me my god okay so
when I get to that point like that's the
only thing that I haven't locked down is
like the unpredictability of like bozer
in that particular area cuz it's a
little wonky it's just a little bit
wonky ain't it it's a little bizarre
like even here like because he shoots
the thing he shoots the thing oh god he
bounces off it was like a sideways thing
why did he bounced up such a piece of
ass okay but it don't matter it don't
matter okay we're okay oh my god oh my
god okay we're fine no oh my god you
tried to murder me you tried to murder
me you ass blasting vasta lloyd okay
yeah come on yeah don't matter here we
go
okay got it now this is gonna be a
little bit of a [ __ ] but if I can kill
bozer it all don't matter
whoa no no oh my god that was not cool
he can't even get new [ __ ] why okay I'm
up here now just get over yes oh my god
but I lost my shrimp oh-ho that's right
they provide another one a nice oh nice
Oh God not this I remember this
okay okay okay I got okay come on come
on
okay here we go not the first one oh
that was probably mistake oh okay bad
start
come on I do all that prep are do all
that waiting I get to that point [ __ ]
jump and then it gets to like this
stupid douche mist where it's it makes
me go off the screen and I can't see
where I am that's the problem of that
one case it wasn't obvious you can't see
where you are so you don't know where
you're gonna land in because you go off
the goddamn screen
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to do
this one I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to even keep trying this one I know
I'm not gonna be able to do it I just
don't know if I'm gonna even want to
keep doing it I mean if I if I rage out
and I might rage out I lose it Amelie
come back to it at a later point but I'm
not ready for it not ready not ready for
Oh God
with your [ __ ] random bowl your
random bowl stop with the random bowl Oh
God I mean it's not random it's like the
springs add an element of randomness
it's not him being random it's it's the
fact that like he's he's controlled by
the springs and not exactly by what he
does so it makes it very difficult it
just it does okay here you know why
would that be the way that that happens
why would that be the way that that
happens it happened that way that is so
stupid that's so stupid
that's so stupid Art's a bag of asses is
so stupid I hate this no just I don't
even know what happened there just stop
just stop
oh my god of course now I you just have
to damage you know damage boost whatever
it is called I don't know I've never
called that in my life you didn't have
to do that thing that they talk about on
grumps thank you everybody so watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
one